Speaker 1: Brazil is going left. Lunatic
President Jair Bolsonaro has lost in a
relatively close race to left wing Lula, who
is returning to the presidency in Brazil. It
is a major Internet international political story.
We're going to talk about all of it. The Guardian
reporting Lula triumphs over far right incumbent
Bolsonaro in stunning comeback. Remember that
this was the runoff election because no candidate
got 50% in the initial election. It was scheduled
for October 30th. Indeed, it took place. Not
surprisingly, many on the American right. Steve
Bannon and others already starting to say it was
rigged. It was rigged. It was rigged. We've seen
this story before. It's the same story. But in
Portuguese we are not going to fall for it. The
Guardian reporting Lula stages astonishing
comeback. Brazil's former leftist president
Lula has sealed an astonishing political comeback,
beating the far right incumbent, Jair Bolsonaro,
in one of the most significant and bruising
elections in the country's history, with 99%
of the votes counted. Silva, a former Silva, Lula
da Silva. Lula, a former factory worker who became
Brazil's first working class president 20 years
ago, secured 50.8% of the vote, and indeed, the
results now have been further counted to 100%. The
results are Lula 50.9%, and Jair Bolsonaro, 49.1%.
Many right wingers focusing on the 5.7 million
invalid or null votes to say no, it was stolen
from Bolsonaro. We will have a deeper dove
into those numbers maybe tomorrow or the day
after. Now, I know that many of you are going to
write in and say, David, it's hard to imagine,
given your skepticism of corrupt left wing Latin
American leaders, that you would be a big fan of
Lula. Now, I think it's important to say many
people don't consider Brazil part of Latin
America. This is a different conversation, not for
today. But to the extent that we are talking about
South America. It is true I'm not even a fan
of Lula, but it is, of course, way better than
Bolsonaro. Now here. Let's talk about this. And
by the way, let me just put out there right now
the people who love to write in or post on Reddit.
David Pakman is a the son of rich Argentineans who
supported the military dictatorship, and that's
why they left with the money from Argentina.
That's the opposite story. Okay. My parents were
and are left wing Argentineans. We lost folks we
knew during the military dictatorship. We left
to get away from the right wing insanity and the
destruction of the economy, not with its support.
So anytime you see comments like that about me,
you should ask what evidence do you have to
support that? So that's not the reason for
my skepticism of folks like Lula. Now, remember,
I'm going to say it again. Were choosing between
Bolsonaro and Lula. I would, of course, vote for
Lula. But what are the reasons I'm not the biggest
fan of Lula? Well, it's a very similar package
to other self-serving South American, Central
American, Latin American left wing leaders. We've
seen that the the routine in Argentina, we've
certainly seen the routine in Venezuela plagued
with corruption scandals, charged in multiple of
these affairs. You can just to pick one. I mean,
there's like a dozen of these. Check out the men's
Salau scandal. This was a major parliamentary vote
buying scandal by Lula's original administration.
He gave in to the horrible Venezuela style calls
to have government controlling media. In 2004,
Lula pushed for the creation of
the Federal Council of Journalists,
as well as a national cinema agency. This is
this is when these left wing leaders do the
Venezuela stuff. We've seen it to some degree
in Argentina as well. I'm anti-authoritarian,
so I can't. Support that stuff. Operation
Car Wash, where Lula was accused of influence
peddling and lobbied for government contracts for
specific, foreign, specific companies in foreign
countries. This would be like Trump or Biden going
to Germany and saying, listen, I would really like
for you to hire Exxon in your country. It's overt
corruption. We would denounce it wholeheartedly.
I would anyway, as a progressive, no matter who
did it, he persuaded the Brazilian Development
Bank to finance specific projects in Ghana and
Angola and Cuba and the Dominican Republic. This
is corruption. This is cronyism. This is the stuff
we hate. I could give you the full list. There's
like seven or eight different scandals here.
And Lula, along with his former chief of staff,
Gilberto Carvalho and five others, were indicted
in a corruption probe as part of Operation Lotus,
which involved the payment of bribes. So sadly,
Central, South and Latin America have been plagued
with these corrupt left wing leaders. And the
sad thing is that you end up with all kind of
bad choices. Look at Argentina when it was, you
know, more Cristina or right wing mockery. These
are not good choices and the entire continent has
been plagued with it. Would I support Lula over
Bolsonaro? Yes, I would. But the idea that this
is some kind of panacea very much not the case.